une première en france des sextuplés
mais cette réussite médicale pose un
problème d'éthique à propos des
traitements contre la stérilité qui
donne souvent lieu à des naissances
multiples verdict attendu pour un autre
vrai méditer les quatre dirigeants
d'action directe condamné à perpétuité
pour l'assassinât de georges besse le
pdg de la régie renault le deuil à
vaujany cette petite station des alpes
dont une cabine de téléphérique gras
moderne s'est décrochée hier soir
faisant huit morts l'installation devait
être inaugurée la semaine prochaine
madame monsieur bonsoir
verdict attendu pour un meurtre
prémédité c'est le premier titre de
l'actualité de ce samedi soir les quatre
accusés de l'assassinât du pdg de la
régie renault georges besse qui sont
également les quatre dirigeants
principaux du groupe terroriste action
directe ont été condamné cet après midi
à la prison à perpétuité assortie d'une
peine de sûreté de 18 ans c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ne pourront bénéficier d'aucune
grâce éventuelle avant d'avoir purgé
cette première partie de leur peine sur
place au palais de justice dominique
verdeilhan pas dire ian 1h15 de
délibération pour un verdict sans
surprise on ne saura jamais exactement
quelles ont été les réactions des quatre
accusés à la lecture d'une sentence d'un
procès qu'ils ont depuis quatre jours
boudé dans les rangs du public quelques
visages ceux des parents d'une des
accusés se sont tendues lorsque le
président versini a déclaré à toutes les
questions
la cour a répondu oui roche entend ainsi
toute circonstance atténuante
un verdict que madame baisse attendait
depuis plus de deux ans qu'il ya quand
même pour nous une grande différence
entre attendre un jugement
de notre institution judiciaire et puis
qui se fait est que nous puissions
redémarrer après un verdict sans
surprise également du côté des avocats
de la défense la défense ne plaidera pas
vos victimes sont trop belles elles sont
déjà condamnés avaient clamé ce matin m
coûtant peyre cet après-midi m ripert
en abordant pour la première fois les
faits eux-mêmes a tenté de démonter un
dossier qui pour lui a été construit
plus qu instruit depuis le début de
cette affaire
nous exposons que ces trois sur
manifestement d'ordre politique même
s'il ne veut pas dire son nom
les exemples que j'ai pris avait pour
objectif de le démontrer je crois que la
démonstration est réussie que la
condamnation élimination de nos clients
n'a rien de juridique elle est politique
elle était attendue elle a été accueilli
sans surprise m ripert en a profité pour
critiquer les mesures d'isolement
carcéral dont sont victimes ses clients
un isolement qui devrait se poursuivre
puisque les quatre condamnés sont
actuellement poursuivis pour d'autres
crimes
trois dossiers sont actuellement à
l'instruction dans la petite station de
vaujany près de l'alpe d'huez dans les
alpes c'est la consternation après la
mort de huit techniciens qui étaient
également des habitants du village
huit personnes huit hommes décédés dans
la chute d'une cabine d'un téléphérique
qui devait être inauguré la semaine
prochaine et qui pouvait transporter
jusqu'à 165 heures par voyage ce soir
vingt-quatre heures après l'accident la
commission d' enquête continue de
rassembler tous les indices qui
permettront d'établir exactement les
causes de ce drame reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux claude rey jean georges
badia
les enquêteurs et les experts
travaillent sur les restes de la cabine
numéro 2 tombé d'une hauteur de 200 m la
remontée de l'autre ben permettra
l'examen du chariot rester accroché au
câble tracteur pour trouver le point
précis de la rupture de la suspendre
il n'y a eu ni problème de freinage ni
déraillage on évoque prudemment une
question de boulonnage défectueux un
problème mécanique au niveau de la kz2
suspension d'une potence prévus pour
soutenir une cabine et 160 passagers
le responsable de la société pomagalski
qui a conçu le téléphérique ne voulait
pas se prononcer les experts rendre
leurs conclusions dans plusieurs jours
savez vous vous êtes sur place sur le
site web le chariot et la wec la benne
est en bas donc une fois que l'on aura
que les techniciens avec les services
auront eu ce qu'il en est c'est à ce
moment là que la commission d'enquêté
nommée par ministre des transports
pourra donner des conclusions
ça doit être la crise est dû ce cas
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit maintenant des
technologies connexes moyens matériels
ce matériel mais nous allons quand même
huile à moi sur le temps humain ça a été
très dur pour moi
les prix comme si cette mise en jambes
un office religieux a été célébré cet
après midi pour les huit jeunes de la
région qui ont trouvé la mort dans la
petite commune tout le monde se sent
concerné le téléphérique devait être
inaugurée la semaine prochaine des
touristes avaient même prévu de
l'emprunter aujourd'hui notre
accompagnateur de sensus nous avaient
dit oui sans nous à l'aide le premier
utilisé ce que souhaitait le fric alors
ce matin vous avez une frayeur quand
même rétrospective humain de tout revenu
c'était pense pour ça aurait pu nous
arriver quoi et le câble le carde qui
est là bas qui vous vrai l'aqip ans iggy
dans l'est et tous côtés et il y avait
un coup vraiment un coup
pour les remontées mécaniques française
c'est le troisième grave accident en
trois ans à vaujany on n'ose pas avancer
de date de mise en service de ce
téléphérique pourtant ultra moderne
oui vous venez d'entendre un touriste
belge dire que le téléphérique devait
être emprunter dès aujourd'hui et bien
le préfet d'isère précise ce soir
qu'aucune autorisation de mise en
service n'avait encore été délivrés dont
il n'était pas question que ce
téléphérique soit prêt inauguré est
utilisée dès aujourd'hui les premiers
sextuplé français sont nés aujourd'hui à
la clinique de port royal à paris deux
garçons quatre filles la mère avait
suivi un traitement contre la stérilité
et comme c'est souvent le cas lorsqu'il
réussit ce traitement est bien ses voeux
ont été exaucés au delà de ses
espérances ce qui pose d'ailleurs un
problème d'éthique médicale sur lequel
nous allons revenir dans un instant mais
tout d'abord l'information la naissance
des six enfants agnès poirier claude
sicard l'émotion d'un père depuis dix
ans il attendait ce moment
cette nuit son épouse a donné naissance
à six bébés qu'est-ce qu'on éprouve
d'avoir de la joie mais bien content que
les six soit bien vrai et en bonne santé
c'était devenu primordial maintenant
après ça va nous poser beaucoup de
problèmes surtout ça vous fait un peu
peur bah oui quand même parce que c'est
encore plus pour nous si les premiers ça
va être
après un combat au départ surtout une
question d'organisation vont enfin ça
devrait s'arranger
les médecins qui ont accouché madame
adam l'on assuré cet après midi au
journaliste cédric gaël coralie mélanie
kevin et dorian vont bien
il pèse entre 1 kg 320 kg 500 les à la
maternité de port royal on est loin de
triompher
moi je jeu steam que c'est pas tellement
bond de montrer que une conscience
sextuple peut aller très bien parce que
pour il tira très bien et nora neuf tirs
ont mal et puis une grosse aux sextuples
c'est forcément une adduction de
l'ovulation qu'on n'a pas contrôlé et ça
à la limite c'est parce qu'on l'addition
de l'ovulation était pas très bien cette
le docteur verdonck se refuse à parler
d'échec le traitement contre la
stérilité qui l'avait prescrit à madame
adam avait provoqué dit fécondation
d'ovule ramené à 6 après un avortement
thérapeutique
on pourrait dire que réduire de 10 à 6
et pourquoi pas - et bien c'est parce
que c'est difficile c'est difficile
techniquement c'est difficile et il ya
des risques importants d'arrêter
totalement la grossesse et vous imaginez
ce que ça peut être pour une femme qui
attendait depuis huit ou d'avant coup
médiatique peut-être première médicale
en tout cas les petits as dans ce sont
les premiers sextuplé français on a vous
l'avez compris en regardant ce reportage
cette affaire doit nous amener à
réfléchir depuis quelques années en
effet lé traitement contre la stérilité
donne souvent lieu à des naissances
multiples ce qui conduit parfois les
médecins à des interruptions sélective
de grossesse comme il est convenu le
dire et ça dans les premiers mois afin
de limiter le nombre de wulf et condé
ce qui à terme et dès aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs pose un problème d'éthique
médicale peut-on sans s'interroger
continuer ce type de pratiques
alain labouze claude sicard
dans l'utérus de cette femme il y a cinq
ans brillant cinq embryons ici sur cette
échographie le prix parfois un peu fort
à payer d'un traitement contre la
stérilité
oui mais il respire respire maintenant à
un mois et demi de grossesse c'est leur
dramatique où il faut choisir en enlever
3 sur les 5 pour que les autres puissent
mieux se développer
voyez la sonde qui déforme la poche et
qu'il est ce pire tout doucement
doucement doucement vous plutôt vers le
bar plutôt vers le bas
voilà oui voilà près bien y voyez
l'embryon qui disparaît de l'image parce
qu'il a été inspiré par la sourde
il ne persiste donc un sac vide
d'embryons la perversion est terminée
face à ce désir d'enfant on se retrouve
avec un avortement à la clé est-ce que
c'est humainement imagina on ne se
retrouve pas avec un appartement on se
trouve avec une situation qui si l'on ne
fait rien abouti à un avortement ou
abouti à une naissance très prématurée
avec de lourdes séquelles pour les
enfants nous en tant que médecin qui
connaissons le risque d'un accouchement
prématuré
malgré les progrès actuels de la
réanimation infantile dans 88
at on le droit de cacher cet aspect at
on le droit de dire aux parents que
s'ils conservent leur grossesse cultive
ses enfants ne courent aucun risque dans
la famille maillard il y avait déjà
trois enfants puis pour les parents
impossible de mettre en route une
nouvelle grossesse alors traitement
contre la stérilité triplé interruption
sélectif de grossesse et maintenant il
ne reste plus que ces petites jumelles
gwenaëlle et gaëlle où je savais qu'il y
avait des risques que tous ses fans
qu'ils passent un problème et de les
perdre tous les trois c'était surtout ça
m'angoisse pu en avoir après on n'aurait
pas eu d'autres enfants avant bon
effectivement à la limite on aurait
peut-être pu se poser des questions et
on
faire évoluer la nature mais bon avec
trois enfants ça nous a paru totalement
impossible d'accueillir dans été triplée
delà du choix des parents attention au
risque de banalisation de l'interruption
sélectif de grossesse car c'est
peut-être la conséquence d'un dérapage
médicale le traitement abusif le
certaine stérilité
le gouvernement a donné son feu vert
pour la remise en route par edf ce matin
de la centrale nucléaire de superphénix
à creys malville dans l'isère dont le
fonctionnement souvenez-vous avait été
interrompue pendant près de deux ans à
la suite de fuites
le redémarrage de ce matin ne lève pas
toutes les interrogations sur cette
installation loin de là et elle sur sa
rentabilité et elle certaines enquêtes
de patrick esther 10h40 ce matin
derrière ce sas blindé à l'abri de sa
double cuda si protecteur le coeur de
superphénix a recommencé à battre et
lentement durant cinq semaines
il fonctionnera à moins de 3% de sa
puissance jusqu'au 1er septembre
les ingénieurs finiront un programme
d'essai interrompue par la découverte
d'une fuite dans l'installation
une fuite de sodium situé ici dans la
cuve du système de chargement
combustible du réacteur
le barillet depuis plusieurs semaines
les techniciens des couples et des
mondes cette installation qui sera
remplacé en 1991 par un nouveau système
fonctionnant avec un gaz inerte
ces tôles sont maintenant bonne pour la
ferraille coût des réparations 500
millions de francs
en attendant cette date le réacteur
fonctionnera sans système de
rechargement en combustible nous avons
examiné tous les cas de fonctionnement
possible
nous avons introduit un certain nombre
de dispositifs supplémentaires
permettant de parer à des accidents que
nous n'avions pas considérer la première
fois et par conséquent nous repartons
tout à fait assuré qu'il n'y a pas de
problème pendant toute cette période
mais les écologistes s'étonnent
aujourd'hui du fait que les mêmes
autorités de sûreté qui avait réclamé
l'arrêt de la centrale
il y a vingt mois autorise son
redémarrage puisque rien ne remplace
actuellement le système dit fuyez ce
n'aurait pas été un drame de laisser
fonctionner l'installation le l'incident
du barillet ne crée pas de risque
immédiat pour la sûreté
par contre de notre point de vue il
n'aurait pas été normal compte tenu des
doutes quand gendrey cet incident que
l'on ne prennent pas le temps d'abord de
réfléchir de tirer les enseignements de
remettre la situation entièrement en
ordre et puis ensuite seulement
d'envisager un redémarrage en totale
connaissance de cause 1 re démarrage
peut être sans danger mais superphénix
mais plus un véritable outil de
production d'électricité laboratoires
industriels d'études pour le siècle
prochain sa rentabilité économique est
un rêve qui appartient au passé ou à
l'avenir mais plus au présent un bon
contre annoncé ce soir pour alstom et
edf en chine 1 milliard 200 millions
construction pour la construction à
proximité de canton d'une usine
hydroélectrique de pompage qui vient
compléter la construction d'une centrale
nucléaire déjà commandé à la france fait
divers sordide triste à la fois
tocqueville dans la manche près de
cherbourg le patron d'une maison de
retraite inculpé et écroué pour
violences sur ses pensionnaires ce sont
des infirmières qui ont dénoncé le
directeur de l'établissement bruno gex
je signale choix oui ce délit gifle et
gignac placé masquer sa sas est donné
sur mon nez voyez tout à l'heure quand
on est arrivé vous avez dit ils viennent
pas pour me remettre dans une maison
parce que vous en avez vous l'avez en
horreur cette maison
jeanne le mot est âgé de 77 ans est
l'une des anciennes pensionnaires de
cette maison de retraite du petit
village de tocqueville qui hébergeait
une dizaine de personnes âgées un foyer
dont on disait depuis un certain temps
qu'il s'y passait des choses étranges
jusqu'au jour où les infirmières du
foyer alerte le maire du village et le
conseil général de la manche j'ai fait
un grand père ou sur le dos aux
toilettes il est en train de faire des
toilettes et comme le grand père voulait
parce qu'il se prêtait pour s'habiller
lui a donné une gifle et jules à
plusieurs reprises insulté des grands
pères et des grands mères est ce que le
grand père et la mère avaient droit de
parler entre on compte éléments il
disons que c'était assez satisfait après
que les services sociaux et déposé
plainte une enquête de la gendarmerie de
cherbourg a conduit à l'inculpation de
michel roupsard directeur du foyer
aujourd'hui sous les verrous il risque
deux ans de prison pour violences et
voies de fait sur des personnes hors
d'état de se défend d'un du mal à y
croire parfois économie